he's Bryan Cranston you can see him well
you can always zoom last flag flying
it's a tough name that's that's fine
it's not I know lff it's somebody's
gonna make a mistake with this oh I see
we're yeah it's not gonna be good here
ya asked flag flying now in theaters
also the disaster artist you're doing
that that's December
yeah that's coming up coming out soon
yeah I just have a little walk on with
that that's oh you doing COEs kind of
there are a lot of stars in that movie a
lot a lot of big names and have you seen
the original of the room no oh God it is
the best worst movie ever made
it is by far the worst movie you will
laugh your head off watching this
because they absolutely meant it to be
completely serious oh and it's just it's
it's so abysmally wonderful who makes
you laugh by just looking at them
whether in person or well on set is
there somebody that you just you lose it
keegan-michael key is just hilarious and
I did a movie with him called why him
last year and there was a scene where
I'm sitting on the toilet and he's it
play he comes in and I could not keep a
straight face I lost it for like 40
minutes and I was mad at myself and God
okay ready ready ready and I and I would
literally be biting the inside of my
cheek like that just clamping down so
that I wouldn't laugh it's it was it was
almost impossible he's so funny
just and and I can't look at him because
just a little movement with his high
brow and I'm gone but you try to make
somebody crack up you do you you yeah
he's on Breaking Bad was so serious that
did you you didn't try to do it then
didn't know but sometimes you get a case
of the giggles and you get lost and you
just cannot keep a straight face on
doing things it's it happens and then
you just you try to you know gather
yourself and come back and and you know
focus but it's hard but you're doing
so many different things now now you're
doing Theatre in London right the great
movie Network which I think won an
Academy Award didn't hit wait won
Academy Awards uh the the character I
play is Howard Beale and Peter Finch won
the academy award posthumously actually
died just like three days before the
Academy Awards but he was tremendously
influential and a great actor and I get
to play that role and say that iconic
line I'm mad as hell and I'm not gonna
take it anymore
Fritz he's been doing it go ahead that's
pretty damn good actually
give him some props that was awesome
thank you yeah okay McLovin try it what
I would think that that's one of those
lines but you get lines that are
delivered to you all the time now that's
not your line because it was from
Network but do you get lines repeated -
I get the Breaking Bad lines all the
time you know say say my name or I am
the one who knocks or I mean oh yeah I
am the danger there's all kinds and then
I'll get Seinfeld lines - like there's a
little sticker LeFleur but when you read
those lines from Breaking Bad those feel
like repeatable lines because they just
stand out I mean it just floats out
there that it's just on its own I guess
so but at the time we were doing them it
it wasn't it didn't feel like we're
doing an iconic show where you know
people can't set out to make a classic
you have to just focus on on telling a
good story and if if the fans say no
that's a classic television show then
that's who determines but when did it
become a classic while you were filming
I guess I guess it was late it was
because we started in o8 and I was
probably about oh I guess about 11 or 12
that it really started to catch on but I
look at it like like the Hall of Fame
there's a reason that there's a waiting
period because you don't want the energy
of someone's last season that oh my gosh
absolutely Hall of Fame you give it five
years and then if you still think that
that player is was amazing then yeah
that's how he should go and I think
that's smart did you ever give any
thought no no any thought to this being
a dream of house with malcolm in the
middle' that Breaking Bad was just a
dream in the last scene now am I crazy
to say that well you're crazy but you're
not crazy crazy you're not crazy you're
not insane okay I thought it would have
been an unbelievable ending because
people are always disappointed with
endings you know the final episode but
if all of a sudden you just wake up and
it's how who wakes up and well it's
funny you should say that because I
pitched just that and we shot it I
pitched an idea that Hal wakes up and
he's scared and he wakes up his wife
next to him instead of Skylar it's Jane
Kaczmarek who played Lola it's in the
DVD extras from from Breaking Bad and we
shot it as a you know just a little
sketch and that's it and I said oh I got
scared I was cooking yeah yeah yeah but
wouldn't that have been not that it
wasn't a great ending because it was but
that's one of those and like so people
are still upset about The Sopranos
we've never been upset more if you did
it that way than the way you did it do
you think oh I think so okay I think so
I mean there's so much pressure on a
show that's ending to come up with the
quintessential finale there's a lot of
pressure and I didn't know what was
going to happen I didn't know until like
four days before when I read it but I
thought Vince Gilligan did a masterful
job in creating that final Breaking Bad
he's Bryan Cranston he's busy he's in
the movie last flag flying in if you see
the home man cave you gave us is it a
prosthetic yeah what is that what you
would describe it so you're in
bed yeah and as a vietnam vet coming
back home no that's from a different
movie it's a different movie
wait yeah it's a completely different
movie
wait the phallic symbol is from a
different movie than last one I have
more than one phallus in different yeah
I carry them with me I sign them and
give them away to fail okay wait so are
phallic symbols from what is from a
movie called the upside with Kevin Hart
okay and that comes out next year like
March or April or I've been telling
everybody when I watch the trailer I go
you know Bryan sent us or something for
them okay yeah no no it's it's okay so
it's not okay nevermind I have a
different phallus surprise in last flag
fly you do not really but I just thought
I'd tease it no I screwed it up it's in
theaters now that's really a good movie
by the way it is Laurence Fishburne
Fishburne Steve Carell it's real funny
guy very funny guy let me take a break
we'll talk a particular yeah we'll take
a break and I want to ask you about
Charles Manson - okay yeah yeah he's
dead by the way he is
yep but you saw him when you were well I
was as close to no okay you are you're
such a tease denno and Rick okay
he's Bryan Cranston we're back right
after this he might be the best actor of
our generation
wait a minute I'm here to know I'm
talking about you talking about you Oh
Bryan Cranston no I I was telling people
the diversity of what you've shown
whether it's on stage a TV movies I know
there are great actors and I don't know
who you keep you consider like Daniel
day-lewis or DeNiro or Denzel or what
I'm talking about range you know I love
DeNiro doing Meet the Parents yeah I
thought that that showed a comedic side
that's really hard to do
who is the best actor in your opinion oh
gosh you know it's so hard but yeah I
mean certainly Denzel has has that range
he doesn't have humor I'd like to I'd
like to see him do a comedy of things I
keep trying to do things that that scare
me a little bit if I if it if it
frightens me I think I I want to go
toward it and I know it's strange and
and the the bigger the more challenging
the role the more attraction it has to
me but with malcolm in the middle'
tougher than breaking bad because
comedies tougher than drama in some ways
in some ways but but not always I mean
the idea of going to work and and you
guys do it here you go to work your job
is to entertain be spontaneous be funny
and be knowledgeable on everything
that's going on in sports yeah that's
that's a lot on your plate yeah if you
were just knowledgeable in sports but it
wasn't entertaining you guys wouldn't be
on the air that long yeah it just
wouldn't work
no so you have a lot to do and that's
the same thing you go to work you have
to be funny you have to tell the story
with on stage it's different you have a
relationship with an audience that you
just don't have and film the television
and I like that part you get to see
somebody's reaction as opposed to on TV
or in a movie you don't know how we're
reacting right do you ever alter your
performance in theater on stage when you
see a crowd's reaction to you all the
time constantly you're constantly making
little adjustments throughout a
performance and then you you have a
thought in retrospect you go maybe
tomorrow I'm going to try
that I'm gonna delay that line just a
second more before and and your constant
just like a bird in flight is constantly
maneuvering and changing its angle of
the wings that's the way I feel like
when I'm on stage nothing is set you're
constantly trying new things
what about Curb Your Enthusiasm it's so
much fun but that that problem what are
you told by Larry David Larry says okay
here are the he gives a page of a scene
says here's your character you're my
therapist and the one responsibility in
this scene and for example is that you
need to to somehow get out that you
really enjoy truffles and you and your
wife love truffles and you know it and
so that's about it and then his
responsibility was to get in this one of
the scenes we did it was that his his
disappointment with the chair that I
supply for my patients and so that was
his responsibility at some point during
the conversation so he that's up to him
and my my responsibility at some point I
have to get out truffles how do you do
that you know and so but it was
interesting how we did it and you know
what he kind of quiz me will suffer and
what do you do and I want my wife and I
this is truffles week we go out to a
different restaurant we love you know
and so that's how we got into it but
it's so much fun do you do that a lot
yes you could I would love to if Larry
if you're listening to this program
which for there's no reason why you
should he knows nothing about sports I
would love to come back and do it
especially to play his therapist again
you know that's that's fantastic
all right last flag flying 30 years
after serving together in Vietnam you
have Steve Carell and you also have
Laurence Fishburne you reunite different
type of mission you're gonna bury Steve
Carell son yes then you're going to New
Hampshire to bury him well at first his
we're three Vietnam veterans we knew
each other and something went down that
was not kosher in back in the day
Steve Carell paid for our indiscretions
and and we felt as fish and I our
characters felt responsible and guilty
about it and and trying to deal with
PTSD in our own ways
in the meantime Steve Carell son joins
the Marines goes to Iraq and
unfortunately gets killed and so it his
he's going to be buried at Arlington
with full honors and yet a couple things
don't seem right in the story and Steve
decides I don't want to do that I want
to take him back to New Hampshire and
bury him in our next to his mother and
so it's it's really sweet and heartfelt
but it's very funny as well and we have
a blast and it's it's male bonding it's
an honest male bonding movie but it's
emotional and it's tough it's a dark
comedy it's it's it's kind of alternates
with with drama and comedy I wouldn't
say that it's a dark comedy because it
doesn't follow a straight line to that
but it it encompasses manliness and how
we how we deal with grief you know most
of us you're talking to man cave most of
us when we have problems we deal with it
privately and then we come out of our
man cave and we handle it you know and
these men try to do the same thing but
it's not always working that way and
it's really it's really a beautiful film
I'm really happy with it and Richard
Linklater is the director and he's a
genius
oh yes yeah the movie last flag flying
and it's in theaters now I saw where you
growing up had an encounter with Charles
Manson who just passed away
we just had Mike Love or the Beach Boys
on I know Mike was talking about how
Dennis you know the drummer yes cousin
was trying he was trying to get the
Beach Boys to join Charles Manson's
group well you know to his credit
Charles Manson had a great group they
were hot they the the guitars
it was like insane but okay you're you
didn't know that this Charles Manson he
was crazy Charlie to you well my cousin
and I used to go horseback riding at the
Spahn Ranch which is in yeah it's a
community
north west of Los Angeles and it's very
rural and we would go up there horseback
riding and the last time I did I was
about 12 it was 1968 or slate 68 I think
fall and we're renting our horses and
some guy came in and started screaming
Charlie's on the hill Charlie Zelle and
we it startled us real holy what would
happen and the old guy who was renting a
sword said don't worry about don't worry
about it and he everybody there maybe
eight to ten people men and women jumped
on horses and galloped away and we were
wow what was that well the old guy
brings out two horses that you know
Central Park horses that are come and we
start to do our horseback ride in the
same direction where they went about 20
minutes later we see a trail of horses
coming back and the the the width of
this trail is maybe 10 feet so horses
have to pass by each other very closely
and in the middle of this pack there was
one little man with black hair and dark
dead eyes who was on the horse but he
wasn't holding his own reigns the the
guy in front of him was on and he was
just sitting kind of wildly like this
just like going with the movement of the
horse and he was just out of his mind
and my cousin I are passing and we're
looking at him like oh my god and I
looked at him carefully as he was
passing and my cousin said that must be
Charlie and then we didn't think a thing
of it the following year we see all that
the man then tate-labianca murders and
there have been arrests and here's the
picture of and it was like oh and that
was I get on the phone of my cousin and
she's like I was just about to call you
Mike
it's like that was Charlie Manson in
your 13 years 13 years old I was 12
years old kind of hard to process that
it didn't and then again when I heard he
died and saw his face again and saw
pictures of when he was younger it was
like oh my god it had it was almost like
turning a switch like ooh I'll never
forget that face and that's why I'm
positive it was him because it was such
a big deal that you know Charlie's on
the helming and then staring at him on
his way back and it was just indelible
in my memory have you ever thought doing
sports movie yeah I'd love to
what would you do is there something
that hasn't been done or is there
something yeah there's there's uh
there's a story I want to tell about the
Negro Leagues actually about to pay
tribute and an homage to the Negro
Leagues and but do you like would that
be something you voice over or no it
would be something I want to write yeah
I went to I was in Kansas City on a tour
of promoting something and and I had a
day off in his raining and I went to the
Negro Leagues museum and it was just
fascinating the Monarchs yeah the
Monarchs the kings the obvious and and I
meet Buck O'Neil I didn't I know my gosh
he should be in the Baseball Hall of
Fame he he would show up when when
players from the Negro Leagues would get
inducted the Baseball Hall of Fame he
would go and speak on their behalf
because they weren't living he did all
of these wonderful things contributions
to the game now he's since passed but
yeah Buck O'Neil was just a treasure
because he was that link to this
forgotten time right and boy can you
imagine what that would have been like
had integration been law of the land and
having these great ballplayers have that
opportunity and I wanted it to to bring
it up to current times so it's like it
seems like African American there's not
a lot of African Americans playing
baseball anymore and I thought I wonder
why I'm not sure but I'd love to tell a
story that connects the old world to the
two now and see
if there's a link to it and do it in a
dramatic way an entertaining way so a
movie or documentary it's a movie okay
I'm conjuring a story already and about
how to how to bring it up to up to speed
so did the Dodgers break your heart if I
would have told you at the beginning of
the year you're going to the World
Series but you're going to lose Oh would
you have signed up for that oh so hard
oh my god so okay so in June I said this
is the best chance that the Dodgers have
had in almost 30 years because they
weren't supposed to win in 80
in 88 yeah the big underdog yeah and the
Mets were a much better team so I said
let's get Verlander let's lock it down
I even had a hashtag hashtag Verlander
in blue lock it down well I think I
don't want to say I'm pressing it but
come on if if we had gotten Verlander
instead of you Darvish we win the World
Series I don't think there's any
question about that because Darvish
would not have been our pitcher for two
but Verlander would have taken his place
and if Darvish had ended up with the
Astros and then you got so much the
better
yeah oh God
but it hurts it you know it does and I'm
glad it does you're the true fan yeah
you're a true fan at anyone who doesn't
feel a little pang of pain when your
teams don't win then you're you're just
a mild you know fair-weather fan do you
got good seats
I do get seats because you're Brian
Krantz I checked the schedule and I I
said I said to a friend I said can you
connect me with seats when the Eagles
come to LA to play the Rams in December
he goes yeah you got it I'll set two
aside and it's like see that's the good
thing are you going to be Superboy if
that's celebrity man Rams go to the
Super Bowl you're on the Super Bowl I
don't know if I go to the Super Bowl it
there's so much pomp and circumstance
connected to that and I'm still dating
the Rams
remember they left me I'm from LA they
left me for another city the stench of
another city was all over them no matter
our you want me back you're gonna have
to earn me back what if I have Jared
golf Koya but he brings phallic symbols
with him wherever he goes prosthetics
wherever he goes he's got one in his
pocket right it's flying in theatres now
the great Bryan Cranston thank you guys
great to see this give us the line from
Network one more time Bryan just happens
to be here thank you bro it's passed
that's it we're back after this for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]